I wanted to ask you about you have my
kids are in their teens but still kind
of early teens you have a daughter that
turned 21 just I'm curious what is that
like I'm just exploring because I know
that that's headed my way in five six
years but I want to know what it's like
I just got drunk with her what you got
drunk with you're a 21 year old because
it's it's legal I realize like I think
we're allowed to do this now wait I
think you should he should look into
that and so I was with her and we were
at this event and and after threated
this is this restaurant bar that had
this kind of like weird kind of cool
Haitian drink and they were like do you
want some and I realized oh I'm allowed
to have this with her and and she she
got very drunk and I realized something
about it I didn't know which is she is
way cooler drunk daughter is cooler
drunk way cooler
she's suddenly like hilarious she's
doing voices
she's like the anti Mel Gibson have a
friend I felt bad even when she's been
drinking yeah I know bad that I ever
like like hid the liquor yeah I think
you did the right thing when she was 11
12 I think you made the right call
well what's okay what is it what about
boyfriends what is that like it's it's
so weird because I just lived with women
and so sunny there's a boyfriend around
and that it's an intimate relationship
for me
no ever talks about like my relationship
with the boy because there's never any
man around and I'm so excited I'm like
do you like Pearl Jam and then out of
the blue they'll bring cup with them but
they don't check with me and I'll come
home I'm like where's Kyle I can't call
him right because the instantly are not
allowed to call you can't like call
secretly and be like can I'm calling you
from a burner phone
that's how yeah I didn't think about
that
that's a crush